Hi and welcome back to Breakfast Club.
You are still with me, Shah Shamshiri.
And I promised you earlier the very beautiful and talented young woman I have next to me: Shila Amzah.
Good morning, Shila.
How are you?
Hello, good morning.
Okay.
Feeling good?
Yeah, I feel great.
Okay, because I always feel bad.
I'm sorry.
I repeat this every time with my guest because it's true.
I always feel bad taking people out of bed early in the morning.
I already got used to it.
Oh, you already got used to it.
Are you a morning person by the way?
I'm not really a morning person,...
...but my mom always forces me to get out of my bed.
Okay, that's good.
That's a good mother.
We were talking about empowering women,...
...so women should wake up early in the morning.
Oh yeah.
Okay, but I know that of course, it's very different for people in the entertainment world particularly singers,...
...because I know a lot of entertainers, singers, morning is not really a good time.
They're usually more night people because you guys have shows, you guys record at night.
A lot of things are done at night.
Okay, anyway, now we've met Shila Amzah.
You may have remembered her from the reality show 'One in a Million' a few years ago,...
...and she got second place.
Yeah.
And now, a lot of people keep calling you Shila One in a Million, Shila OIAM.
So now, do we address you as Shila or Shila Amzah?
Shila Amzah.
She preferred to be Shila Amzah.
Now for your information, Shila's father was a very famous actor in the 80s particularly.
I remember when I was still a kid watching him on this show.
I forgot he placed his hair stylist...
That is.
I forgot, yeah.
But her father is ND Lala.
He's a very well-known actor and he was also a singer for a while, I remember.
A singer.
Actor, and then now he's a businessman.
And now, his daughter is one of the top singers in the country.
Everybody's talking about her.
Young, upcoming, it's true.
She's got a very beautiful voice.
So you know, very, very beautiful.